next tuesday the house commons is going
to vote on a new set of measures to
restrict the spread of covert we've just
been hearing from the secretary of state
are you going to support your government
well i'm expecting four votes i will
vote against vaccine passports i'll vote
against extending a face mask mandate
i'll vote against uh mandatory
vaccination as a condition of nhs
employment the fourth one is a slightly
liberalizing measure i don't expect the
house to divide but yes i will vote
against i think what we're doing now is
creating a miserable dystopia that into
which we're going forward and that's why
today i'm announcing that i'll be
relaunching conservative way forward we
need to create a movement which actually
says the conservative party needs to be
what people traditionally have
recognized as conservative that is in
favor of freedom and personal
responsibility so i hope people will go
to conservativewayforward.com
and sign up as supporters and they'll be
the first to hear more
presumably you wouldn't be launching
this if you didn't have some support
do you have any idea how many members of
parliament will join you uh from the
conservative benches in voting against
the government on tuesday
well the spectator has run a list on
this and they've got 65 names on there
it's not absolutely clear to me that
they'll all vote against some may
abstain but i know about half a dozen
extra names so it feels to me that it's
going to be at least 60 people voting
against but of course it's a foregone
conclusion because our useless
opposition in name only uh will continue
to support the government however
authoritarian they are but you know
really this is a moment where every last
one of us should in good faith start
thinking about what it means with to
live with coronavirus like we live with
flu now that we're vaccinated and what
kind of society we want to live in in
the future i want one which is free
which is prosperous and which is joyful
in which young people can have a hope of
a better future and at the moment when
we're not looking like we're going to
deliver that if we keep on panicking
every time we get a variant this disease
will now be with us forever there will
be new variants the vaccine continues to
give a high degree of protection against
serious illness and death and in
straight we just do now need to get on
with our lives
we read this morning in the newspapers
about dissent in the cabinet and the
possibility that
ministers may resign what do you know
about that do you anticipate ministerial
resignations over
these measures
well i i don't know i mean so far
ministers have voted for a great many
things that they don't like doing and
that's been one of the hallmarks of this
period of the coronavirus you know we
keep doing that which we hate but saying
we'd like to be doing something else
well i'm afraid sooner or later if we're
going to save the soul of the
conservative party we've got to actually
do those things which we love to do and
that means being courageous and
temperate and prudent and think counting
the cost of lockdowns and restrictions
rather than having this endless tunnel
vision just on the disease you know we
we actually can't go on like this
only the conservative party can provide
good quality government that that draws
on the tradition of freedom and
responsibility under the rule of law and
all the time we have minute and
frequently changing rules governing our
lives so that we can't plan forward
whether it's for business or for
pleasure i'm afraid we're going to make
enormous swathes of our economy
uninvestable and they'll be just the
swathes which give our lives meaning
things like being able to go on holiday
being able to go to hospitality venues
you know we saw for a long time that
weddings were in trouble you know these
things really matter in our lives and
pretty soon we're going to have to start
learning why it is that we've always
believed in this country that freedom
under the rule of law mattered and
that's really why i'm re-launching
conservative way forward we've got to
show that there is a movement for that
frame of mind because if we don't the
conservative party will continue to
drift into authoritarianism and i simply
cannot stand idly by while that happens
you um
you referred in a newspaper article this
morning to uh the conservative party
essentially and you've repeated it here
having lost its soul is that
what the johnson administration is doing
burying
the conservative uh soul as you
understand it
well at the moment it we're in a pretty
bad shape you know boris did promise us
that he'd be as he put it a brexitee
hezer and that is what he's done he's a
highly interventionist prime minister i
think we did expect that he had two
really important jobs to do he had to
take us out of the european union albeit
with the unfinished business of the
northern ireland protocol and he had to
make sure he beat jeremy corbyn but i'm
afraid i did expect him to spend quite a
lot of money but i think that the thing
that's really changed now is we've used
so much quantitative easing that is
money creation to cover the enormous
amount of borrowing the government has
had to get us through covid i think now
as we go forward we've got to be
extremely careful to apply conservative
principles to what we do because the
size of the state the size of taxation
is now not consistent with conservative
government it's a it would be you know
fit for a miliband government and much
as i'm on friendly terms with ed
miliband i didn't want to be in his
party
mr baker what what's interesting about
the way you talk about this is that um
you're not talking about it really
as a partisan or even an economic
question
you seem to be posing
the issue as a moral one and that in
some way where the conservative party is
now
is in some sense immoral
in a sense almost ethical or religious
is that your belief
well if i were to to put it to you as
plainly as i can surely life for each of
us is a process of becoming it's a
process of becoming greater tomorrow
than we were today not of comparing
ourselves to other people but comparing
ourselves to what we were and trying to
become better in some sense now if life
is a process of becoming don't we
deserve the dignity of choice as free
human beings with something like a soul
and if you don't have any kind of
spiritual belief well at least come up
with something which gives you meaning
as a freely choosing individual i mean
where are we going to find meaning and
purpose in our lives if we don't have
choice and responsibility and this
opportunity to grow and so that's why
i'm so very concerned that what is
happening here is we're being treated by
the government by the public health
establishment as automata who can't
manage to decide for themselves that
it's a good idea to wear a mask in an
enclosed space i think we've all learned
that now i'm certainly capable of doing
it freely and i'm very sure that your
viewers are capable of doing it too and
really we do need to think very
carefully now about what we wish to
become you know in society are our
relationships healthy when they're
voluntary or do they all need to be
coerced i mean this is a fundamental
question
i the reason i um
frame this or raise this as a moral
question is
partly as you said it's to do with
the question of individual choice but
morality also relates to leadership and
i want to ask you
about the leadership that you have
supported of your party and of the
government that you've supported uh
boris johnson this week um essentially
has been in a whole series of issues
about whether he has told us the whole
truth about payments for uh decoration
flats the issue of the again once again
of christmas parties and and so on
do you think
that
this leadership
uh remains the sort of if i like could
put it this way moral leadership that
you can continue to support or does this
prime minister has this prime minister
reach the end of the road for you
well i'm really clear that i want boris
johnson to be a success i'll never
forget sitting next to him at dinner i
see it in my mind's eye now and he
started to talk about the condition and
the prosperity of the british people in
a way which was earnest and honest yeah
but if i forgive me if i may interrupt
boris johnson i want to see
yeah forgive me though uh
boris johnson's idea of success may not
be exactly the same as yours and what
you seem to be saying here is that uh
success is not just a matter of winning
or getting through it or getting past
the next scandal it is also about what
you believe and how you behave so let me
ask you again
is boris johnson
still the kind of leader behaving in the
kind of way this uh displaying the kind
of morals that you feel
that the conservative party should still
support
i i think right now the prime minister
is in very great difficulty for the
reasons that you're indicating any
member of the public is going to rightly
demand that politicians not only comply
with the rules that they impose on other
people but that they're seen to comply
with their spirit and it's pretty
obvious now that that hasn't happened
and that is it that is a very bad
position to be in but let me be clear
trevor i've been down this road once
before viewers will know and i have
absolutely no intention this time around
of trying to remove a prime minister i
want to see boris turn this situation
around i want to see him rescue his
position i want to see him go on to be a
great success but he's not going to do
it by paying lip service to rules and
being in cautious about how his staff
behave and comply with them so you know
we don't make him prime minister for his
meticulous attention to detail but you
know it is now time a time for complete
compliance with all rules
so you're clear he hasn't followed the
rules if he doesn't turn it around
within let's say a few months is it
going to be time for him to go
well trevor as i just said a moment ago
and i hope you will understand and your
viewers will understand i've been down
this road before and i'm determined not
to go down it again the reason that i'm
launching conservative relaunching in
the new year conservative way forward is
because i think we need to create a
movement which says to boris and the
whole conservative party we want to live
in a society characterized by freedom
under the rule of law and personal
responsibility that's really what i'm
about
steve baker thank you very much indeed